I want to talk about 50 Ways to Leave
Your Lover 50 Ways to Leave Your Lover
is has two different elements to it one
is
I find this this little chord pattern
[Music]
which I like oh it's beautiful what's
that there's one note you hit in there
that it's just so it's almost off this
would I
[Music]
yes that one yeah it's an interesting
it's an interesting chord but anyway
that was the verse
the the chorus the words of that I was
teaching my son Harper who was just you
know young at the time I was teaching
him about Rhymes slip out the back Jack
make a new plan stand only because Roy
or just so that was that was what that
was about the drum part which is one of
the the
most sampled drum parts that's the great
drummer Steve gadd and maybe oh maybe
the premier drummer of my generation or
certainly one of them there are a couple
others it's a great trumpet do I have
that let me see there it is
so you originated that with a drum
machine and then you bring it to him no
no much much more credit to Steve guy
than that I'm playing the song with my
drum machine
and Steve says
I was in the Army Corps of drummers and
part of what we had to learn were these
parade drum things so I would practice
these kind of Beats wow
he said what about that and I said yeah
sure let's try it I mean that's so
iconic that drum yeah it's one well he's
he's a he is a great drummer
thank you